[Music]
I don't know what happened to the bird
s
[Music]
love my mother
okay
so let's get after it
good [__] bread hey let's get after
with Chris Cuomo we got a couple things
first off first what happened to the
bird we don't know but we do you want to
see him getting a pumped getting pumped
before his show
you wanna watch it again what a natural
moment what a what a natural moment
what's going on with that
so
he's about to get real with us
he got a little real with us he ran our
free agent shirts
he had Armor All His tires that's all he
had yeah all he had was an under armor
shirt yeah that is the cure to our
political ills although we're not
talking politics today got to move away
from the parties you got to make them
chase you not vice versa look at
everything we're seeing uh in US right
now you know it's a game you know
they're playing it's so obvious and ugly
but yet but as Soros guy is a good guy
not a bad thing to say about the guy can
I make a small critique Chris
sir um if you're gonna move your hands
around like the guido grease ball that
you are then change the second camera
angle because it's literally right in
front of the hand yeah no it's fine he's
blocking the second camera angle
continues and continues why two parties
One Way Zero Sum binary
so him pretending he's smarter than he
is awesome I love it I mean I hate it
but I do love it but it's just [__]
it it starts to wear on you and you're
like you're not that smart buddy look
the answer to making that better is in
ourselves
um and on that note I want to move into
a man I just keep staring at the [__]
Moss hanging on the wall like what the
[__] oh yeah is that algae yes it's Moss
he's hanging moss on his [__] wall
like a [__] white woman excuse me
Virgie it's called Living Art you
[__] pleb
and
if you look to the right I got a snail
with a snail and a jar with a leaf in it
I cut air holes yeah so he'll be all
right he'll be fine you're doing more
Mitch hedgeberg jokes yes you don't want
to be that's not Moss I'm actually aging
parmesan on two canvases
you know it's not even that he acts
smarter than he is it's that he acts
enlightened which bugs me that's what
makes me want to bury my fist in his
face it's like it's like that story we
heard of [__] at one of the SNL
series Steven Seagal that he the Dali a
lot he paid the Dalai Lama enough money
that he called him a deity and so he was
talking about I'm enlightened now I'm a
God that's who he is
[Music]
you pay the Dalai Lama anything he got
fired because his brother couldn't stop
grabbing cop titties at least whatever
at least he got the good hair plugs yeah
how many intros hold on I'm not going to
receive the library all right so I just
want to tell you guys about my fantastic
sponsors with Bluetooth now I personally
I don't need that [__] not me right now
I'm right about right now I'm like a
[__] I could cut diamonds with this
thing all day long so I I'm just saying
it but they pay me money so if like your
dick don't work properly you know if
you're not a man go to Bluetooth using
Chris Cuomo fun fact that CNN they had
to they have to raise my debt six inches
kept knocking at the bottom with it with
this massive [__] Italian hog yeah it
kept banging on the desk with that had
the mic on everyone thought Alex Jones
was on the air
[Music]
uh the funniest thing about this and
we've no we haven't noticed it but I
just noticed it and I'm posting a
screenshot of the locals if you freeze
frame the title of this show in the
right way it just says the chomo
oh my god oh yeah oh my God he just
posted it local he just posted it along
this is editing Cassie man I have the
eye oh no oh no oh Chris oh Chris Chris
how unfortunate it's not good
well I I would say within a month he
changes the intro of his show
that's the chomo yeah the chomo hey he
on the chomo
oh that's [__] amazing
that's that's karma for the bird yep yep
okay
Greg didn't raise his hand he's such a
punk
um another one passy who makes mistakes
often
see this is the other thing I hated this
fake this fake humility this with the
fake humility and this enlightened like
hey who is not perfect
come on this guy this guy right here I
realize it I'm being self-aware over
here it sounds like an a an N A guy
talking like leading an A in anything
yeah who does it mess up who here who
here makes mistakes huh who's not
perfect I'll raise my hand first you sit
there your grandma's down you look at
the pills you go what's one pill gonna
do
dangerous path take it from me dangerous
path yeah I mean who here hasn't
occasionally covered up sexual assault
when you're Governor Brothers in a lot
of trouble come on oh we're all human
why do you think why do pencils have
erasers
Hey listen I'll tell you this when I
cover up my brother's sexual assault
allegations and refuse to report on it
on the news I still put my pants on one
leg at a time yeah hey you know what I'm
Chris Cuomo you know what I always say
every day is a gift that's why they call
it the present anyway
people say to me every day's a gift I
say ah it's pronounced Jiff
[Laughter]
who makes mistakes often even though
they've told even though his dad was a
famous governor and so was his brother
and worked at CNN I get a specific who
does though well themselves they don't
want to make that mistake again
this one time I was doing a cycle I
forgot to take Clomid never made that
mistake again I cried for 30 days
straight I was in tears every other day
my nipples were so sensitive it's a
[__] mess never again
I got Ryan Reynolds guy now so ain't
gonna happen
I got that guy I work with Chris
Christian Bale on The Machinist he's
gonna help me get lean and cut
he's working with cocaine
um This falls into the category of bad
habits okay
a habit is something you imagine I'm
addictive to one thing working out could
you imagine if your wife goes I got some
friends in town we got to go on a double
date
you go out and then it's these it's him
and his wife and you're stuck at a table
with this [__] listening to him
Babble like this yelling at you why rare
steak is the only way to order steak
getting mad at you if you're what are
your baby medium
you know it's like look we all make
mistakes you know you got to learn to be
humble in life oh this is medium
the [__] so like I was saying it's good
to be humble it's good I'm just glad
we're at the waffle house because it's
gonna have a really weird with a nice
place he expects he expects five star
dining at home do
um cloth napkins in this joint
Savage said I got this place they
respect me really good we're gonna go
eat at this nice Giant and you go and
it's [__] Waffle House oh my God
something that you do in set conditions
meaning uh for instance when you're
stressed out you smoke a cigarette yeah
yeah of course sometimes I'm stressed
out you know 20 times a day 25 times a
day you know
sometimes when I'm stressed out I do
power squats until I Cry
I just [__] power Squat and then I
cry I ball i ball in the corner of my
home gym we all make mistakes like my
wife for instance I tell her the other
day go get bagels from the good places
she goes the [__] Handy Pantry oh I
know it's closer but it won't cost my
happiness my happiness Brenda [__] they
don't even give it the knock test or
whatever
or you drink or you eat right it's not
that you just eat at a certain time
every day I told you to Gino's Pizza and
Saya set not in valley not Valley Stream
what part of those two genos a different
genos what do I gotta tell you every
time hey you got you got marinara in
your ears I said Brazil not brazute
could make that I love this video we
could always just run the clock out
times things trigger behaviors and that
can be a habit in and of itself so I
have done a lot of study on this
he's done a lot of study on this
he sat with many books and he poured
through the data I've been on a tail
lately have you guys heard of this Alex
Friedman guy oh my oh my god he has a
book list my God my own
it's amazing I mean it's some real like
I mean these books ain't no you know
Mario Puzo novels yeah you ever heard of
this catcher and rye bread bro it's a
good [__] bus I haven't gotten to the
bread part yet don't ruin it for me hey
you think you think wrath grapes make a
good Vino
let's Catcher in the Rye ain't got to
the part about the sandwich yet
1984. hey is it about when I could get
Coke a studio 54. I remember that was
84. I remember
oh [__] all I know is that if I owned an
animal farm and they got uppity I'd be
[__] eating them all yeah yeah grad
was reading this book Great Expectations
I had those as CNN so that [__] [__]
fired me
I was reading this uh this dostoyavsky
guy he has the brothers karamazov or
something isn't it a UFC fighter
the guy that fought McGregor in the
parking lot
oh fun you know I read this book Of Mice
and Men was on the reading list
sometimes I hug people too tight too I
get it I get it it happens sometimes
look at these guns
yeah I got retouched string I got a new
book coming out the loud Italian art of
giving a [__]
a lot of work on it
because I mean he ordered his uh Chicken
Soup for the Soul I swear to God I was
reading it just made me hungry when he
lets these walk and talks what about
Italian wedding soup for the soul when
he does his walk and talks or as I call
him his birth funeral processor
he should call them I walk in here with
Chris Cuomo
burn funeral I'm walking here featuring
Birds oh god
of mistakes and often people think I'm
joking when I say I am no I'm never the
one thing I promise you I've never
thought you were choking Chris can we
make an animated series about Chris
Cuomo and the bird oh God you can see
his little sidekick and like it the bird
will just tweet like a regular bird but
he understands them yes like I love an
R2D2 thing
not now we gotta go save my brother the
mic the Mike Tyson Adventure art guy
yeah I like that it never leaves his
hand yes
shocked at my ability to make the same
so do my [__] bench press bro 20 reps
225 did it right in front of him didn't
even sweat a mistake multiple times
but I do especially with negative
behaviors so
I did a lot of research into it and I
have figured out why that is and what I
can do about it to make it less likely
increase my level maybe lower your level
of steroid consumption might help a
little bit full of satisfaction with my
own Behavior Uh and this is because I'm
still paying these guys to fix the
drywall frankly I feel like a [__]
regular I feel like a regular [__]
dang Crenshaw over here A bunch of walls
I'm getting angry he doesn't fix a drive
he's one of those guys he's buying
paintings
this house looks like the [__] like
the [__] like the Louvre
hahaha
those around me who are affected by my
behaviors
but guess what that's why those two
framed pictures of moss are hanging
behind them is just [__] when I punch
the Moss I don't break through the
drywall
I don't do it so I know the answer I'm
going to give the answer to you because
I hope that you have better Fortune
better chance better opportunity in your
own life to make this stuff stick okay
I've done the homework I have made the
mistakes and I know how to make it
better but I really struggle with it and
I think part of that is just a human
condition part of it is just being
flawed and of a certain age and I think
maybe that's a little bit of an excuse
but I'll take you through the research
here's research here we go so basically
what I'm reading on is Notepad
off of is uh this this is
retreat
what is it this looks like when Bam
Margera started his own language resist
resent
what the [__] is this it's can I explain
to you what it is Royce uh this is what
happens when a [__] overthinks yeah
that's what this is it's what a [__]
over thinks when a guy he's got a he
wants to come up with something
like that's his but again he's a [__]
so this is the best he could do it's
this horrible [__] he's trying to
write a book it has to be this is what
this is leading to well didn't he write
a book and it got scrapped
no was it it was working on it but he
said it in one of his videos that he was
working on a book and then the whole
thing happened at CNN and then they
didn't want his book and now that he
could sell a book again but like it was
I guess all covered era nonsense and it
just wouldn't be a book now yo Chris
only a thousand views on a video Jesus
Christ bud when Chris Cuomo right works
on his book I picture him like
Christopher from The Sopranos with his
laptop yeah
all right I think that's pretty much it
with Chris I mean you know we get we get
the gist that he's [__] stupid I love
him yeah he's a [__] idiot but he's
he's my favorite idiot oh yeah I I out
of all the people we cover Chris Cuomo
is has always been my favorite
um hey Sage [__] put you know that in
that chat uh GPT thing
he he put this in and this is hilarious
oh my God I was just screaming through
it
here we pull it up he here's what he put
He asked it
give me a funny sketch where Chris
Cuomo's over the top Italian but is best
friends with a bird that he talks to but
doesn't speak English but Chris
understands him all right ready first
read Chris Cuomo go ahead yeah okay hey
Tony how's my favorite theft friend
today
I know I know you're just too good at
imitating me but let me tell you Tony
you ain't got nothing oh my not a
spaghetti sauce
hold on
can we make this a show yes
keep sending us more stage please can we
use can we make Chris Cuomo Chachi BT
bird episodes and just have somebody
animate them
okay here we go right here we go
oh
hold on
no that's that's not good where's I want
generic Italian music what do I type for
that Italian restaurant
there you go there we go
hey Tony how's my favorite friend and
friend today
I know I know you're just too good at
imitating me well let me tell you Tony
you ain't got none of my Nana's
spaghetti sauce
oh you think you can make better songs
all right here we go breaking news with
Anderson Cooper
[Music]
foreign
[Laughter]
so the bird's gay
so the birds of FANUC
foreign
oh my god dude I had a really stupid
idea
and uh who was it that did this Sage
retired Sage [__] turned a stupid idea
into Brilliance this needs to be a show
it needs to be its own channel we need
to make our own separate Channel Mike
shealy as Chris Cuomo with joy of pessie
as Tony the bird so he put He put in
there he put in there uh this time oh
yeah he's kind of gay it would be
appropriate to make a sketch for a
fictional characters and Kurt to adopt a
certain political igl why because too
many people were making Nazi lizzo
fanfic but this is fine
Nazi lizzo fanfic is very give me a
story where lizzo's playing the flute
but she's leading the third right in a
per in like in like a parade is there a
chat GPT thing that's like not gay
they all started off not gay and then
they had to put in some [__] God that
was really good [__] that was really
good feather that's my my favorite
feather friend today
oh [__] Tony
bird squawks and responds
Tony Sparks again
I made the bird in him go to the gym no
you didn't did you really oh that said
it to me
yeah we have one more episode
all right hold on hold on
okay okay so this time
all right this time the bird and Chris
Coloma will have an evening at the gym
and proper lifting techniques
hey Tony how's my favorite feathered
friend today
that's the spirit Tony we're in the gym
tonight you ready to pump some iron
that's what I like to hear let's start
with some warm-up exercises Tony hops
under Chris shoulders they begin to walk
to the gym
[Music]
all right Tony first we're gonna work on
our chest now when you're lifting it's
important to keep your back flat on the
bench and use a full range of motion
seat like this inhale as you lower the
weight and exhale as you press it back
up
thanks Tony you're a great spotter now
let's move on to some bicep curls
the bird flies under Chris shoulder
now keep your elbow close to your body
and both Swing Away
[Music]
Stoney you're a great workout partner
let's finish with some cardio
all right Tony that's a wrap for the
night go work out buddy
so dumb
this is the best thing that's ever
happened ever in the world thank you
for the taper Thank You Sage for this
thank you so much
holy [__]
oh my God
just him telling a bird and he's the
only one that could understand the
cartoon rules bro R2D2 rules is so good
oh [__] Chris and Tony that's the name
of the show it's Chris and Tony